The conversation about the differences of parenting,
from boomer parenting to millennial, respectful,
gentle parenting,
whatever you wanna call it,
often times gets wrapped up in this idea of being grateful
or ungratefulness,
when in reality,
this is actually a conversation being had in the same language.
We're talking about needs being met.
This is Maslow's hierarchy of needs.
Pause to take a look.
Now, where a lot of older generation parents get really
tricked up with this whole conversation
is they feel like we are ungrateful because they provided these,
these baselines, safety,
security, and physiological needs,
and perhaps they didn't have those growing up.
So talking about needing more or wanting more
or not providing enough when those were met
does come from a privileged place
because not everybody gets those met.
However,
if we're talking about doing better for our children than what we had,
those of us who started with these base levels of needs being met,
which again, food, safety,
roof over your head,
you know,
even going beyond and above that with opportunities and education,
we are very grateful about these needs being met
and can still acknowledge that these needs were not met.
Doing better for our kids can start at any one of these levels, right?
As long as we are striving to go up the pyramid.
So it looks like this commenter did that.
They went above and beyond what they got as kids,
and they feel like that should be Enough.
And maybe it is.
I don't know. I'm not their children.
But I do know that those of us having this conversation
are also just trying to do better for our kids.
We're just trying to go up the pyramid for them and for ourselves.
We have the privilege of knowing
that these baseline needs are going to be met
simply because of the financial privileges
that we were either raised with
or we have created for ourselves,
for our family.
So we are focusing on the psychological upgrading,
basically to foster self esteem,
love, belonging,
intimacy, connection.
Because either we feel like we didn't have that
or because we were taught how to do that by our loving family.
Those of us that are, like,
reparenting ourselves and doing this by ourselves,
we take issue with not getting these as kids.
Not that we're ungrateful for these.
Very grateful for these.
Still wish we had these because we would like to get here,
and we want this for our kids as well.